violent headless is an interesting term
in software development like you can say
can we run that headless or does this
have a headless configuration I'll be
honest when I first heard that term I
had no idea what it meant basically let
me paint you a picture in this wonderful
piece of terminology a computer you know
like one of these things is considered
to be a human body yeah this is already
weird the main part of the computer is
like the actual body and I suppose like
the limbs might be in input devices like
a keyboard or a mouse I don't know but
we're coming to the important part the
head the head is like the monitor the
screen I guess that makes sense because
it's on top either on a desktop
especially like the old ones where you
had the main computer down the bottom
and the big CRT monitor on top or a
laptop it's like kind of on top usually
now if we were to take off you know my
head I would be headless and if we draw
this back to computers then we would
have a computer without a monitor so how
do we use computers without monitors
well usually we would like remotely
connect to it from another computer you
know like via SSH or something and then
we would have a terminal command line
where we could type out commands much
like sshing into a web server you can of
course use a GUI remotely but for the
sake of this we're going to stick with
the command line and that's what
headless means it's just a console
application an application without a
graphical user interface no window no
Graphics no rendering just a command
line application generally though this
terminology applies specifically when we
have a version of that program with a
GUI like for example a game engine we
might want to run like all of the
systems of that game engine but just not
output a video signal this has lots and
lots of different uses from testing to
running a server recently I made a
little app called walnot chat an instant
messaging app that I wrote in C++ using
my walnot application ation framework to
demonstrate networking in C++ video will
be linked above that app has both a
client and a server application the
ladder of which can run either in a GUI
mode or as a console app so in other
words headless this was important
because I knew that I wanted to deploy
This Server onto a VPN I needed it to
run on a Linux web server that I could
then SSH into and use without a
graphical user interface so I added a
headless configuration to Walnut which
means that we can keep the exact same
app functionality but just either
compile the program with a GUI or not
this enabled me to write the code for
the walnot chat server just once and
then just build it in either of those
two configurations this enabled me to
write the code for the Walnut chat
server just once and then build that
into two fully functioning applications
one GUI and one console this headless
app was then built on Linux and deployed
onto our web server in this video I'm
going to cover how I set up that
headless configuration in walnot and how
it works all of this code is completely
compl open source you can find it on
GitHub links will be in the description
below now if you're new to programming
and computer science and you want to
learn more then there's an excellent
free way that you can do that with a
sponsor of today's video brilliant.org
for those of you who don't know
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of brilliant
courses on various St topics as I
mentioned programming and computer
science they've got some excellent entry
level courses on that kind of stuff
they'll really kind of be gentle and
hold your hand and take you through like
thinking like a programmer which is
obviously very important and the thing
is because this is brilliant we're
talking about they'll do that in a very
visual engaging interactive way it's not
just going to be here read this or watch
this video it's actually going to get
you to do things to play with like all
of these different widgets and to answer
questions they'll quiz you to make sure
that you're paying attention and
actually learning and that massively
helps you remember things now you've
probably noticed from the visuals here
that it's not just computer science and
programming their math courses are
honestly my favorite across the entire
internet and it's because they have this
visual approach to learning they have
this engaging kind of interactive
approach like trust me I do a lot of
math I do a lot of teaching and I love
this stuff I think it's the most
effective way to learn now the best
thing about brilliant is that they have
a 30-day free trial so you don't have to
take my word for it you can just go to
brilliant.org Theo and check out
everything they have to offer for free
for 30 days so just give it a go it's
free there's like no reason not to at
least try it out and if you do go on to
like it then brilliant have been nice
enough to offer the first 200 people 20%
off an annual membership huge thank you
to brilliant.org as always for
sponsoring this video all right so now
I'm going to show you how like all this
comes together and actually works first
and foremost at its core this is really
simple we just want to compile our code
one of two ways either with all of the
stuff that's necessary to actually make
the GUI work and one without I would
definitely say that that is step one
because once you get that working you
can build what you actually need on top
of that and by building building what
you need on top of that I mean
alternative functionality to interface
with the application so as an example in
a GUI you would obviously have like
buttons maybe like a in the case of
Walnut chat an actual UI control to
enter your text message if you have a
console App instead then I mean you
obviously need some kind of other
interface for that which is usually
going to be the command line you can
both output to the command line and then
you can also you know take in input from
the command line and use that to send
your messages execute server commands
that kind of thing so to kind of
summarize step one just be able to
compile the code with no GUI stuff in it
and then step two build extra
functionality on top of that so that you
can interface where required so of
course I'm going to start with like the
whole build process I'm going to use
Walnut chat as the example here but the
fundamental library that kind of
supports this is my Walnut application
framework Links of course will be in the
description below if we take a look at
the root directory here of just WN not
chat there are two scripts there's build
and build headless now if we go into the
actual ual Walnut module you can see
that there's also build Walnut external
and build Walnut headless external now
Walnut uses premake to actually generate
project files so that's why these are
all kind of lure files and we'll run
them by executing these scripts either
for Linux or for Windows that will run
the pre-make binary which will be over
here for Linux or for Windows premake
5.exe and we'll get our kind of WN not
chat solution and WN not chat headless
solution now I probably don't need to go
through these build scripts like very
very fine grain this code is on GitHub
you can just read through it yourselves
but I will quickly just say that this
headless kind of configuration first of
all it has this kind of workspace wide
Define and that's so that if we do run
into an area of the code that is clearly
GUI only then we can just selectively
compile that only if well not headless
you know isn't defined and obviously
vice versa if we have something that is
command line only then we can also just
use that Define to kind of pick and
choose bits of our code now that's not a
great strategy for like like the main
kind of meat of things which is why we
don't use this as much as you might
think and I'll explain the alternative
in a minute other than that you can see
the most kind of important thing here is
we are including the Headless external
version of Walnut so instead of build
Walnut external which is just that's the
normal one we have build Walnut headless
external and if we quickly just take a
look at the differences between these
two you can hopefully see that the
Walnut external version has a lot more
stuff and namely what it has is stuff
like Vulcan and like glfw and IM guy
none of which are present inside this
Walnut external headless variant because
of course we don't have I am goey we
don't have glfw and we don't have Vulcan
we don't have any graphics that need
rendering so it's kind of like a boiled
down more simple version and of course
we don't need to include these projects
or link any of these binaries because
they simply don't exist this is also
really useful if you're specifically
compiling on a platform which might not
have a GUI or you don't support the on
that platform so as an example for WN
not chat at the moment on Linux it's
headless only like we don't have JFW and
I'm guey and Vulcan and all that kind of
support on Linux I just haven't added
that yet and I didn't really need to all
I wanted to do was just run the server
on Linux that didn't require any of this
stuff so instead of kind of wasting time
getting all of these dependencies like
I'm guy gfw and Vulcan Vulcan AR really
a dependency but getting all of that
stuff kind of built for Linux
specifically I just haven't had to do
that because I didn't require that
functionality now that's probably not a
great example because long term I do
actually want to add Linux support
properly like to Walnut but my point is
maybe sometimes you have an application
that really you have no interest in kind
of adding L full Linux support too but
you still need it to run as a server on
Linux so therefore you don't have to
kind of put as much work into that
because you don't need to worry about
all of these dependencies working with
Linux so that's kind of just the
binaries we're selectively including
certain binaries and also certain
projects because you can see with this
kind of include stuff if we go to this
kind of vendor you know glfw folder that
should definitely be uppercase um but
you can see we have this pre-make 5
script which obviously you know compiles
gfw so this is like an actual real
project that gets included we just
simply don't need it here and so now
since we don't have like glfw or IMU or
anything like that how does our app
still work because we've just cut out
like the main core of it like if you
have an application that has a window
that is obviously kind of core to the
main application Loop like you know we
use gfw to pull all of the events so
that we can see like is the window still
open have we closed the window what
about like key events and mouse events
we use JFW for that so if you cut that
out then what is what does your
application Loop even look like and
that's a great question and that's also
why we basically need two different core
application Loops we need a GUI version
which includes gfw it will render all of
the IM guey stuff using Vulcan like all
of that that kind of infrastructure that
needs to exist for the GUI version but
then for the Headless version we need a
completely different application Loop
that basically excludes all of that but
it still runs our kind of core user code
which is written in Walnut using layers
so that itself is kind of easy to set up
as well all we have in Walnut is inside
the actual Walnut directory we have two
kind of folders here we have platform
and then we have source source is the
source code that is common to basically
all the platform so this is like all of
the core source code whereas the stuff
under platform is stuff that is specific
to certain platforms or configurations
so that might be actual operating
systems like Windows Mac and Linux it
could be rendering apis like vcan or
direct F or it kind of could be
configurations like GUI or headless and
of course for this example it's the
ladder so if we go into platform you can
see that we have GUI and headless and
then under GUI we have Walnut and we
have have all of this code that is
specific to the GUI kind of
configuration so all the kind of IM goey
stuff input event kind of handling UI
stuff as well as this main application
file which we'll get back to in a minute
image is also something that is GUI only
of course and then if we go back a
little bit to headless you can see we
also have this kind of same folder
structure and then in Walnut we have
application headless so you can see that
we have kind of two different
application files application headless
and application Walnut and what I should
have also mentioned here is that the
whole point of kind of separating these
out inside this platform directory is so
that we can only compile this GUI folder
code in GUI configurations and only
compile headless code under headless
configurations and it's not even just
compile it's also include so the cool
thing here that I'll just try and show
quickly is that under walnut's Source
directory we have this kind of Walnut
folder right and then under one of the
platforms we also have Walnut so the
whole point here is that that when you
include these files in your C++ code you
actually don't know what is coming from
platform and what is coming from Walnut
because if I had this directory as an
include directory and I also add this
directory as an include directory then
the files from both of those directories
are able to be included if you do like
hash include Walnut SL whatever and
that's really important because it makes
stuff a lot more seamless so the
selective compilation happens inside the
actual Walnut premake files so if we
look at the GUI build script and also
the Headless build script you can see
over here that under files which are the
files included for compilation we have
either platform headless for the
Headless variant or platform GUI now
these are not just files for actual
compilation they're also just files that
are included in the project which is why
you're seeing header files here as well
and then under the include directories
similar thing we have source of course
for both of them but then we also have
platform GUI or platform headless so
that we can include files in those
directories by just going like hash
include Walnut SL whatever so now hope
hopefully this is starting to make sense
we have a GUI folder that has
application GUI and then we have a
headless folder which has application
headless but that's still a little bit
annoying because it means that since
these files are named different things I
have to in my application manually type
out either include application headless
or include application GUI but wait
there's a better way since they are
actually named application headless and
application GUI that leaves room for a
third option and that is just inside the
source directory called application.
there's no CPP file for that and what is
that you may ask well this is the code
for that it just has that if def
headless include this guy otherwise
include this guy and so we're able to
selectively choose which one to include
but from the client side and in fact
even from walnut's own internal code all
we have to include is application. and
it will include kind of you know
abstracted away behind the scenes the
right kind of variant okay so that is
basically all of the kind of build
configuration stuff that I want to cover
if we now go and open up like Walnut
chat headless and I'll also open up
walnut chat which is the GUI version
I'll show you the differences in code so
one of the important things I want to
touch on here is that like if you look
at these applications so we we'll look
at the server because really the server
is the thing that has that headless and
not headless configuration I didn't
bother making a headless version of the
client because I knew that would always
be GUI so under app server we have
server app this is just a standard kind
of entry point in a way for Walnut
applications and there is this little if
andf Walnut headless just because we
have a menu bar that obviously uses IM
guy and isn't available if the app is
headless so you can kind of just ignore
that but aside from that you can see the
code is identical like this project I
guess I should point this out this
project here these actual kind of bits
of code here they're for both versions
so we didn't create two different
applications that would defeat the whole
purpose we still want to retain as much
much original kind of I guess GUI code
as possible when we make that headless
variant and not specifically GUI code if
I'm being pedantic but just kind of
General application code so this will
push the server layer on and you can see
the server layer has all of these
functions that are overridden that we
can use to you know actually like start
the server when the layer is attached to
the application as well as you know on
update do things like Ping The Client
List to everyone save the message
history so all of this stuff is actually
common to both the Headless and GUI
versions because you know we still need
to do these things now on UI render
clearly is specific to GUI so that's
again behind this little Walnut headless
thing now there are more clever ways
technically to set this up if you really
don't like these if and Fs you could
make another CB file that is selectively
compiled only in the kind of GUI
configuration that contains all of this
because it's not like you have to
implement this function in this specific
CB file but for this kind of Walnut Chat
thing like I really didn't didn't want
to over complicate things I just thought
this actually ended up being cleaner so
this basically we don't do but
everything else here like if I just look
at this uh Walnut headless and just like
search for it so this we don't do and
yeah that's it so everything else here
is common to both the Headless version
and the GUI version which is great now
if we go back a little bit just so that
we can see the actual kind of way that
this application works so again we have
application and then inside here we have
either headl or GUI as I mentioned if
it's application GUI then well this has
a lot of stuff and I've talked about
this many times this is not definitely
not the cleanest file I've ever written
uh and it's like a thousand lines of
code that just does kind of application
stuff and IM goey stuff and Vulcan stuff
so this is kind of the meat of it but
meanwhile we have this application
headless version if I switch to the
Headless solution so this is now the
Headless solution you can see it's
including this one instead and if I go
to that code you can see we have kind of
this same the same rough stuff here
that's required we still have like a
name a width and height which is a
little bit redundant but the reason why
that's there is because if we wanted to
we could still kind of you know specify
a WID and height for the window that
could just simply be ignored otherwise
we would need to have two different
specifications or selectively compile it
just gets a bit annoying and then if we
look at the implementation file it's not
1,000 lines of code it's 84 much much
much less but it still follows like the
same principle where we have obviously
you know layers that are being attached
and then we have a run Loop which is
while running we go through and we
update every layer as you would expect
we still actually have the frame time
and the time step being reported as you
would expect uh but then we have this
like sleep duration so that we can just
kind of release that thread and let it
sleep for a bit and that is specified by
the actual application specification
because you might want your server to
kind of be a bit more responsive update
a little bit more or you might really
just want to run it I don't know once
per second which is also fine now it is
worth noting that like you know when we
have applications that have uis we
usually limit this kind of application
Loop to be no more than the monitor's
refresh rate so if we have a 60 HZ
monitor We Run The Loop 60 times per
second if we have 144 HZ 144 times per
second that's really easy to do because
as long as we have an app that actually
renders stuff especially using like a a
graphics API like Vulcan or opengl we
can just wait for vsync and what happens
there is we'll still kind of effectively
do the same thing as sleeping but it's
handled by the graphics driver for us
this is very simplified obviously in
like a game engine you would have
different Loops running at different
frequencies for different things not
everything is necessarily about
rendering and thus tied to vsync but
that is still nevertheless a common
thing to do here we don't have any
graphics API we don't have the concept
of async we can run this loop as fast as
the processor will run it but we don't
want to do that because that will fully
saturate a core and if we really only
have a little bit of work to do at
regular intervals we can just set an
arbitrary sleep value and that should be
fine so that is what that is for that
honestly I think covers like the the
main bulk of it and certainly covers
step one which is just getting those
kind of two configurations running but
then we come to step two which is the
interfacing system how do we interface
with this if we take a look at the GUI
version of the server we have down here
this message box we have this send
button we have like all of this kind of
message history if I write something you
know I can type it in I can send it by
just hitting enter or pressing send like
we have obviously this UI this user
interface that we use to kind of
communicate to and from this computer
application so the Headless version
obviously also needs that and if I run
the Headless version you can see that we
still get our message history we're
still listening and I can still write
you know hello from headless I can still
write you know chat messages and I'll
get them here and of course if I had
clients connected it would send that
message to clients and if clients were
writing stuff I would see it here I can
also run certain commands like kicking
you know a client which obviously
there's no one connected here so in this
scenario it's kind of easy to create
that interface because what we have in
the GUI version is almost like just a
GUI version of this of a normal kind of
command line it's like literally just a
console so to make that happen in server
layer I just have two versions of this
kind of console we have a walnot UI
console which is just the kind of IM
version of the console you can see down
here here that it it uses IM to
actually render like that big kind of
message box I guess that big text box
with the history as well as like you
know this input text that we can use to
write the actual message you know the
send button all of that stuff and then
we also have a headless console which
you know is similar to UI console but
for non guui builds and the way that
that works is because you know obviously
just rendering the messages and being
able to send messages that's just one
function of this API of this class that
can be abstracted away really what's
important is being able to know whether
or not we've actually written something
and sent it so that we can then send it
to all the other clients and Echo it
back into the actual message history as
well as displaying messages that we've
received and so that's why the WN not UI
console has an API for adding messages
so we have quite a few options here
because we can display it with an italic
font we can display it with a color we
can display it like bits of it in bold
all of that kind of stuff and so if we
simply want to display a message in that
console we just call one of these
functions and then we also have this set
message send call back function which
that will just set this kind of message
call back and then if we hit that send
button or we hit enter it will just call
that call back with our message buffer
and then back in the server layer you
know here it is set message send call
back to this send chat message function
we can go back and either run the
command if it exists or actually send
that chat message to all the clients so
you can probably tell here that there's
no reason why that same API of just
adding messages and also setting a
message send a call back why that same
API can't just apply to a regular
terminal kind of console and of course
it can now a lot of these guys won't
work meaning like you know this italic
font or like add message with color
color of course we could do but I didn't
bother doing that that doesn't really
have to be implemented it can just print
the message as normal but the point is
in the UI version it added it to the
message history whereas in the Headless
version it just uses C out to print it
and then with the set message send call
back well what we have is we have an
input thread so a special thread that we
create that literally just sits there
trying to read like the line that we
type out and hit enter to and then if
that happens we call the message send
call back so that we can then again send
that message so we do fundamentally have
two different implementations but with
identical API meaning of course we can
call them interchangeably and the way
that that's done is inside server layer
we just have if it's headless then you
know use the Headless console otherwise
use this Walnut UI console and if we go
down here again the API is identical
over here we can just call add tagged
message which will either add it to the
message history and then use I'm goey to
render it or just see out it the message
send call back of course is the same on
UI render is only called if we're not
headless so that's how the IM goey stuff
gets rendered but otherwise you know if
client disconnects we just call this the
message send call back we'll just call
send chat message it doesn't know if
it's come from a headless console or not
the point is that this API is identical
therefore it really doesn't matter if
it's this or if it's this class they're
the same now you could have set this up
using just like an interface of just
pure virtual functions and then two
different classes which Implement those
functions that would probably be like
the traditional kind of object-oriented
way to do this I honestly saw no need to
do this especially for this example this
was just a little bit more
straightforward although I could see a
version where the actual ending kind of
resulting code within this layer would
have been cleaner if the interface
abstracted the implementation away and
then then you could like selectively
compile you know the GUI version for gii
builds headless version for headless
builds and then have like either a
compile time or a runtime branch that
just picked one of the two
implementations and that would be fine
that's how we actually handle multiple
kind of different rendering apis like
Vulcan or open gel in Hazel but again
you have to draw the line somewhere and
for this example I thought this was fine
and that's really all there is to it
it's not that difficult remember if this
stuff is kind of confusing you just
remember I need GUI stuff for the GUI
version and I need non GUI stuff command
line kind of only stuff for the Headless
version how am I going to problem solve
that how am I going to set up those kind
of two different ways of writing this
application whilst keeping as much
common functionality as possible meaning
I'm not going to write two versions of
the app I'm just going to write one core
version and then just the interface and
the graphical stuff that stuff is going
to be selectively picked just keep that
in mind and feel free to obviously read
the source code links in description
below now headless configurations are
not something we currently have in Hazel
but that definitely is going to be
coming cuz we want to be able to do more
networked stuff and potentially better
testing as well so it is really really
useful to be able to build your engine
or your application framework or
whatever in a headless configuration
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please don't forget to hit the like
button as I mentioned all of the source
code will be on GitHub for free links
will be in the description below if
anything in this video is confusing to
you the code might help clear that up so
definitely check it out and also don't
forget to check out brilliant.org Theo I
will see you guys next time goodbye